so here's a fun question what would
happen if you were walking along the
road one day and then Steve Rogers
walked by you and you said hey Steve
Rogers and he's like what's up and you
say your mama wears combat boots and he
got pissed off and punched you as hard
as he could what would happen would you
live would you die would you wish you'd
never said his mama wears combat boots
well that's all we're gonna figure out
today we're going to answer the question
what would happen if Steve Rogers
punched you as hard as he could so a few
things one I've made this excel
spreadsheet right here and what this
Excel spreadsheet is going to do is it's
going to give us an answer it's going to
give us the answer to the question what
is the power of Steve Rogers what
happens if he hits you we're going to
try to find the answer to this
calculation force equals mass times
acceleration now this is all going to be
easy I'm going to put in all the numbers
and all you guys have to do is just say
wow that's crazy and then yeah we'll
just go from there so what we're going
to do here is we're going to look at
Steve Rogers in the scene from The
Avengers whereby he was punching the the
I guess the heavy bag that's what you
want to call them not really sure what
the correct term is here but we're going
to time these little intricacies here so
the first thing we're going to time is
from a position whereby he has his fists
cocked back how long it takes him to
make contact with a punching bag so if
you guys are ready let's try this okay
so that was fast
0.02 seconds that's absolutely nuts he
punched in a fraction of a second so
going to our Excel spreadsheet what we
can do here is we can punch in 0.02
seconds all right what that tells us is
he was moving at 0.04 miles per hour
what we did is we took this 0.2 second
calculation or 0.02 second calculation
and we punched it in and we converted
meters per second to miles per hour and
so from here the next thing that we do
is we ask the question when he punches
the bag how long does it take from the
bag - I guess leave his fist and
actually get knocked off the chain and
then land on the ground all right what
that's going to do is it's going to give
us the acceleration of the bag it's
basically going to tell us how much
force he put onto the
itself so if you guys are ready yeah
let's jump into this okay so that was
ridiculously fast that was absolutely
nuts now what we're going to do here
with that time frame 0.4 seconds or 0.04
seconds is we're going to put this in
here initially as feet all right what
we're going to say is for the sake of
argument the distance between where he
was standing and where the bag landed
we'll say it's about 11 feet or so so
we'll go ahead and we'll punch in 11
feet here now we know that 1 foot equals
0.3048 meters and so this is the
calculation that we get now putting in
the time will say zero point four and
think seconds it was all right what this
tells us is that when he punched the bag
that when he hit the bag the bag came
off and landed at eight point three
eight eight point three eight two meters
per second squared I know it's kind of
like you know crazy but just bear with
me for a second all right
so what we do here is because this is
square but we can't really represent it
then we're just going to punch this in
here as eight hundred thirty eight
meters per second now
we're going to say for the sake of
argument that the bag is I don't know
let's have er heavy bags I mean heavy
bags normally they go anywhere between
110 to 120 pounds I think or something
like that so we'll say we'll say like 55
kilograms all right the force in which
he hit that bag was 46,000 and 19 News
all right off the top of my head doing a
calculation I'd say that's somewhere
around 90 100 pounds that could be wrong
somebody correct my math or somebody
check and make sure that I'm right here
those of you guys who are watching
basically meaning that from a standing
position with his arm cocked back
hitting with full force Steve Rogers hit
that bag and knocked it off the chain at
90 100 pounds of pressure that would be
like getting hit by a Ford Excursion
traveling at 26 miles per hour that's
Steve Rogers standing at a resting
position that's not Steve Rogers running
up on you and punching the hell out of
you while getting punch
Steve Rogers would not be enough to
liquefy your brain it would certainly be
enough to shatter your skull so I hope
that answers your all's question this
was fun we can do this more often like
what would happen if the war threw his
hammer at you that would be nuts that
would be a ridiculously difficult one
but that'd be fun to do that'd be
interesting I think it'd be a lot easier
than this one but it'd still be pretty
fun so anyway I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace
you